bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
du samsung galaxy note 8
le tout dernier smartphone de samsung
qu'on attendait depuis un petit moment
après le fiasco retentissant du 9 7
les dernières qui a coûté à peu près 9
milliards de dollars de perte pure à
samsung
ils reviennent en force alors qu'on
pense enterrer la gamme samsung galaxy
note n'est pas de retour avec un samsung
galaxy note suit plutôt bien fait plutôt
intéressant mais assez décevant pour
ceux qui connaissent pas je suis
monsieur grrrr je parle de stratégie
youtube vous êtes à faire évoluer votre
chère et faire grossir mais je parle
aussi des produits d' influence je parle
de smartphones et je parle plus
généralement aussi de high tech parce
que j'adore ça et je ne pouvais pas ne
pas parler effectivement de ce samsung
galaxy note 8 un produit qui a l'air
sont à pied plutôt séduisant mais qui au
final nous laisse un peu sur notre faim
il a des points qui sont vraiment
positifs mais des points qui sont aussi
extrêmement négatif si ce produit vous
intéresse allez le voir ici en rien vous
allez voir c'est un produit qui est
plutôt pas mal mais qui par contre est
très très cher trop cher
il a passé la barre des 1000 euro
symbolique ça y est on y est à voir en
face ce que apple proposera avec son
iphone 8 mais là en tout cas on est sur
un produit qui est extrêmement cher
autant l'année dernière il y avait des
gros problèmes de batterie il ya eu des
rappels sur le samsung galaxy 9,7
autant le nôtre 8 son problème à
savourer j'ai d'ailleurs très bientôt
réaliser un test de ce produit jeu
d'ici je pense à peu près une petite
dizaine quinzaine de jours je vous ferai
une vidéo de test qui ont pour en parler
plus en détail honnêtement on va
regarder un petit peu basket hand on va
passer très rapidement sur des
techniques un écran infinitis il a que 3
pouces amoled quad hd plus en forme à 18
points 5/9 bord à bord une résolution
qui s'affichera par les faux en full hd
plus vous pouvez vous définir les
paramètres en quad hd plus on peut faire
du multi fenêtres du multitâche c'est un
produit qui est vraiment très pratique
très sympa grand écran vraiment se
régale en termes de qualité de l'image
il est livré avec un respect qui va vous
permettre de certains mal de choses là
très clairement le style et on s'adresse
plutôt à un usage professionnel
le particulier n'utilise pas trop de
cela dit moi d'ailleurs vous en
commentaire est-ce que vous utilisez des
styles et sur vos smartphones est ce que
vous trouvez car l'intérêt veuille ou
non on m'a par ces noms sauf sur un
usage professionnel il peut y avoir un
réel intérêt ce stylet vous permis de
faire du dessin de la priver notre
rapide vous pouvez personnaliser vos
messages pour dessiner dessus et
connaissant des licences des photos vous
pouvez faire une sélection intelligente
pour fermer des gifs animés une
ouverture rapide à grandir facilement
pouvait bien l'utiliser pour la
traduction en pointant des mots qui vous
seront traduits il a une pointe fine et
4096 niveau de pression différente alors
ce samsung galaxy note suite est livrée
forcément avec l'as eupen d'emile de
rechange un bloc de recharge l'adapteur
micro usb usb ces adaptateurs usb usb
ses tableaux de recharge usb c'est
l'aide porcine microsd et des écouteurs
à cacher là où le note 7 avait rencontré
deux pourront rompre avec la batterie
ils ont revu un peu la matica la baisse
on est sur une 3300 millions vers heures
il faut savoir que le samsung galaxy s
suite à une 3500 mis en période alors on
n'ose imaginer effectivement que la
batterie ni optimisés par rapport au
fonctionnement général
le problème c'est qu'on retrouve sans
marche aujourd'hui des batteries jusqu'à
4000 minogue erreur qui fonctionne bien
sur des marques qui sont très connus et
là son cours en une 300 millions
d'erreur ont dit qu'ils vont jouer un
peu petit bras alors ce qui est sympa
c'est l'appareil photo on a un appareil
photo en 12 mégapixels zoom optique x 2
et 1 double stabilisateur optique la
mise au point se fait en direct et
surtout il ya un double capteur qui va
vous permettre de
les votre profondeur de champ avant
d'avoir pris la photo elle-même après
avoir pris la photo ça s'est vraiment
bien vous voulez modifier une photo vous
avez deux objectifs peuvent être un
objectif grand angle avec une ouverture
à 1.7 et l'autre un téléobjectif avec
une ouverture de points car après ce qui
est décevant c'est que de 12 mégapixels
on retrouve déjà sur le galaxy s est il
ya une évolution su mais ça n'est pas
une claque
la caméra de cette fille c'est une 8
mégapixels avec un autofocus
intelligente et une ouverture en un
point c'est côté performances il est un
processeur dit à nous mettre exynos 1995
6 gigaoctets drame un chargeur à
induction et toutes les caractéristiques
techniques vous pouvez retrouver sur le
galaxy s 8 en termes de notification
iris reconnaissance faciale le capteur
d'empreintes digitales qui est situé
derrière qui est pas très pratique l on
prête des retours positifs là dessus
sont les suivent vous avez un mot de
passe vous savez aussi toujours le
modèle pour déverrouiller le code pin en
termes de sécurité je pense que là on
est pas mal il est compatible d'aix
bigoudis dit bettini toujours pas en
france s était une hérésie pour ton
pense qu elle s était déjà sorti il ya
quand même quelques bons mois il est
compatible avec la caméra agir pour cent
soixante et bien sûr avec le casque vert
il est seulement disponible en moyenne
64 gigaoctets un peu dommage quand on va
s'en trouve le prix de ce produit parce
qu'il est proposé à 1901 produit qui
sort le 15 vous pouvez précommander
d'ailleurs si ça vous intéresse
on a rien dans la description il est
disponible en noir carbone ou en or
topal on peut monter jusqu'à 250 gigas
avec une carte microsd
ça c'est bien mais c'est vrai que pour
un produit qu'ils passent les 1000 euros
64 gigas ça fait un peu petit bras
c'est le problème de ce produit si vous
voulez c'est globalement un samsung
galaxy s suit avec un grand écran avec
un peu plus de ram mais qui par contre a
la même capacité de stockage l'appareil
photo et mieux on peut faire des plus
belles photos on peut travailler pour la
profondeur de champ là on reconnaît un
petit peu bansko propose apple et son
iphone 7 plus mais on reste quand même
sur notre faim côté batterie on est en
dessous ce qui se fait sur le marché
avec les 3300 milliards erreur est un
peu dommage
alors qu on comprend très bien que ça me
souvenais pas voulu prendre le risque le
note 7 est un fiasco parce que la
batterie chauffer et que le smartphone
et est même dangereux mais là on est sur
un produit en italie on le prend
complètement la stratégie de samsung
aujourd'hui c'est sortir un produit
avant que apple annonce la sortie de son
acte
s'ils le prennent de court qui vont
beaucoup de précommande c'est des gens
qui n'y auraient pas chez apple n'avait
pas acheté un galaxy mode suite à 1900
euros pour ensuite aller acheter un
iphone 8 ça n'a pas de sens à moins que
vous ayez énormément d'argent
auquel cas vous pouvez faire mais pour
le commun des mortels on doit faire des
choix alors est-ce que ce samsung galaxy
note 8 à un intérêt je suis embêté parce
que oui c'est un super appareil c'est un
super produit on peut pas dire qu'il
n'est pas bien mais on peut pas dire non
plus qu'il est top il est pas
révolutionnaire le s était sorti il ya
quelques temps attendait que nos tweets
qui est une vraie révolution est là
globalement c'est pas ça c'est un
produit qui reste dans la gamme qui
avaient des 8es suite
note 8 mais il n'est pas une énorme
claque bien évidemment les retours
négatifs que taper sur la suite n'ont
pas forcément été corrigé par rapport
aux 28 on imagine qu'il ya des process
de conception syndication qui sont longs
la chaîne de production s'est
probablement monté l otan même si des
retours ont été faits sur la fuite sera
probablement sur la gamme d'après
notamment pu imaginer sur notre 9 et sur
s 9
on voit fond sur un grand galaxie
ensuite la différence c'est le grand
écran c'est l'appareil photo c'est le
style est forcément il existe passion de
la suite c'est la mémoire vive mise à
part ça il n'y a pas de grande surprise
il manque un truc ça c'est vraiment
dommage alors est ce qu'on doit attendre
l'annoncé d'apple pour l'iphone 8
oui et non oui si vous aimez apple si
vous trouvez que la marque intéressante
que vous hésitez vraiment entre samsung
et apple attendait très clairement
l'annnonce de la chronique qu'il saurait
tarder si maintenant apple c'est pas du
tout votre truc vous voulez changer que
le suisse était bien nous pas plus que
ça que vous attendez le nom de suite que
vous voulez un grand écran à ce moment
là vous voilez du sucre est clairement
c'est un bon produit qui se tient et je
pense que vous serez pas déçus si vous
hésitez entre le futur iphone 8 et de
galaxies de suite attendez de voir que
la propose 9 heures locales polar
pouvoir comparer entre les deux produits
parce que je pense ou d'avoir des
surprises d'autant plus que snow de
suite il ya quand même quelques défauts
déjà il propose un système exploitation
ces deux androïdes 7.1 points en liga
qui est sorti déjà en décembre de
l'année dernière alors et qui m'ont
devrait y avoir
à jour son prochain os android mais pour
l'instant il y en a pas qui sort avec un
os qui est déjà adapté c'est quand même
dommage pour un produit comme ça ils
ignorent toujours pas de bixby ça le
second a quand même pu mettre un coup de
collier pour sortir du bio - cet été et
que au moment de l'annoncé de la sortie
du galaxy note 8
il y tourne dessus ça aussi c'est
vraiment dommage après un petit défaut
qui n'en est pas vraiment y'a pas de
haut parleurs stéréo
aujourd'hui c'est quelque chose qui se
démocratise et qu'on ne retrouve pas
chez samsung samsung qui est le leader
du marché
ça reste quand même dommage alors on va
pas cracher dans la soupe c'est un bon
produit c'est un produit qui à mon sens
c'est trop cher parce qu'en même les
mille euros c'est un cap psychologique
et camille leur autre temps d'accueil
avec un petit peu plus en plus sexy
dites moi ce que vous en pensez en
commenté à l'afp que vous trouvez que le
produit est bien ce que vous envisagez
de l'acheter c'est quelque chose qui
pourrait vous intéresser je vous dis je
vous ferai une vidéo dans quelques temps
de test du produit
je vais aller à l'ifa berlin 10
septembre donc je vais le tester
directement vous de montfort et on en
prend là d'ici quelques temps je vois
mal ce n'est pas aux regrets cette vidéo
elle vous a plu laisse-moi des jolies
pousse un bon niveau la chaîne parce
qu'il va y avoir beaucoup d'infos sur la
stratégie youtube pour réussir sur
youtube aussi sur tous les produits des
fluence et sur le live et quant à moi je
vous remercie et je vous dis à très
bientôt pour de nouvelles vidéos salut
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]